foreign
and I walked out of the Emmys recently
okay did I tell you about this you
didn't tell me about this so our last
film which you walked out not went to
you walked out where you went to and
then walked out yeah
so our last film
was called lessons now it's on Netflix
and to my surprise I got an email one
day that was nominated for an Emmy and
so now the minimalists are Emmy
nominated which sounds really awesome or
whatever it's a this achievement that I
never strived for and it just sort of
showed up we wanted to make a beautiful
film that resonated with people and I
felt like we accomplished that anyway we
get to the Emmys and uh they sent us at
the table with Matt Paxton who's one of
the
um hosts of the TV show hoarders which
was quite funny and so we're at the
Emmys and we are watching the award
ceremony I apologize to matthewvell our
director we didn't win the Emmy we're
sitting there watching the uh the series
or the the ceremony and they're giving
out these awards for various you know
technical things and
and we get to a point where they're
giving out the award for the best
advertisement
and I look over at Ryan
and he looks at me
and he goes I don't think we should be
here
I looked at him he sort of gave me the
nod we've known each other for 30 years
so he just gave me the nod and I stood
up
and he stood out
we both just be lined for the door
in our tuxedos yeah I'm loosening the
collar as we head to the door and
Matt you've been to award ceremonies
I've seen you in pictures with ties on
and and you know the CMAs or whatever
and it's not that I'm I think the Emmys
are inherently bad or evil or anything
like that I think awards for art are a
weird thing yeah
because it's not an award for like the
most albums sold that one is
quantifiable totally get that right but
best album according to whom
because I can guarantee you if I go back
and look at the list of best albums
they're not on my list of best albums
yep so what you said about the Emmy is
really what is the best thing about the
Emmy is that you can say Emmy nominated
I would love to get nominated for Grammy
um
but and and I also enjoy a good ceremony
where there's like I go to the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame ceremonies all the
time
and it's fun because it's like I get to
watch musicians be musicians on stage I
get to watch like people talk about they
do speeches that are moving and then
they come together and you get to watch
these bands play you know I've seen the
Cure I've seen the Chili Peppers you
know
but but the but the award thing is like
a circle jerk it's like created by the
company that then gives Awards within
the company it's just a way for
capitalists to sort it's you know and
again I keep harping on this idea but
it's a very capitalist idea like let's
create a situation where we celebrate
each other and we give out Awards to
who's the better one but we really you
know it's like and it's all rigged and
it's all dumb and it's all doesn't
matter and so I used to love the Grammys
watching them and I still love them on a
certain level because I love watching
people play music and I love that kind
of thing but yeah if it's not your thing
like it it totally should I I back it I
back getting up and leaving do you know
what I mean but it's like because it
doesn't not only does it not matter it's
literally like it's like you're make
it's just making things up like an Emmy
for the best and then these people got
nominated these people didn't and
there's a group of people in a room that
make these decisions and those people
like we talked about those people
wouldn't I wouldn't want those people to
decorate my bed bedroom you know what I
mean or like come tell me what you know
it's like so why the hell do I care what
they think about my record it's only fun
because you get to say like Grammy
nominated and then that looks cool and
people talk about it and it's like it
helps your brand it helps move you
forward in a cool way gives you
legitimacy to people that need
legitimacy in order to pay attention
I'll take a little bit of that but like
fundamentally it's just a circle jerk
it's like people sitting in a room
looking at each other being like yeah
you look good that's great keep going
and then like yeah should we let him in
no don't let him in how about her maybe
yeah let's let her in okay great and
that's like you're great you're great
and it's like it's a it's like sit I've
sat on a couple boards in my life uh I'm
out on that too like the you know boards
for like schools and stuff and uh it
just isn't my thing it just feels like a
big it's just there's no
it's just talking about things that
don't need to be talked about
the award ceremony was was fine like we
got dressed up in tuxedos and it's not
my my scene it's not a thing that I like
doing but Ryan wanted to go so I was
like hey we'll we'll go to this thing
we'll sit down we'll watch the award
ceremony but it felt stiff to me
it's the opposite of what you do with
your music where your music feels so
alive but the ceremony celebrating the
music can feel so dead in a way because
it's not celebrating you that's the
point it's like even if you'd won
they're not celebrating you they're
celebrating themselves and it's like
it's just a big it's and again
throwing a party for yourself I bet I
back it you know what I mean if that's
what you want to do and if for you going
was an experience where you're like I've
never been to the Emmys this is cool and
then you go and you're like oh this is
neat I've had enough I'm ready to be
gone like I've act that too but it
really is not the awards are not for us
they're for them to perpetuate them and
their importance you know when they when
you nominated uh something for an
Academy Award and it wins
is it really about because it's the best
movie of the I mean like what that's the
craziest [ __ ] I've ever heard you know
what I mean it's like yeah so going with
the throw up it's like throwing a party
for yourself analogy if we map that on
to winning an Emmy or Grammy it'd be
more like hiring five random people who
don't know you to throw a party for you
and then on the day of your birthday
nervously hoping that they actually
decided to throw you a party and then
after the decision is over you realize
that these were not people that you
hired anyway they were chosen for you
and so if they ignore you you can't
complain and if they throw you a party
it doesn't really mean what you thought
it meant right it's just this completely
random thing it's not it's not something
like
a vote right it'd be one thing if if
they said hey every year we're going to
give Awards and we're going to have two
Awards we're gonna have like the the
mathematical one where like the movie
that sold the most you get a certain
kind of reward because that's a
measurable achievement but then we'll
say hey look all the moviegoers come out
and vote this way and then we'll have
the most popular movie right the
people's favorite comedy the people's
favorite drama that would mean something
right because you get that award and you
would say all right this means that I
sold the most tickets or this means that
even though I didn't sell the most there
were a lot of people that were moved by
my movie and you can kind of make sense
of it but a lot of these awards they're
just sort of like these really elitist
committees we don't really get to know
anything about who has the seat who's
making the Judgment every year there are
complaints about who's represented in
these seats they're they're always
disagreements over that and um they're
always just categories that are left out
for no other reason than that the people
who make the decision decisions just
don't respect that kind of movie or that
kind of Comedy as legitimate art even
though it sells a lot and the market is
signaling that people love it so I don't
have a problem with Awards per se
but as someone who actually loves Awards
ceremonies and what they can represent
in their highest form I definitely uh
empathize with a lot of the criticisms
that people make of how they're
structured and how they're ran and even
to the advertising Point we've talked
about this before
I love creativity and salesmanship I
love the art of creating value and then
letting people know you have a product
or a service that can solve their
problem but the problem with the way
advertising is set up is that it is
feeding into this culture of fear where
nobody's saying what they really think
nobody's making the joke that they
really want to make nobody's laughing at
what they really think is funny the
people who are religious are afraid to
actually admit what religion they follow
the people who aren't religious are
afraid to admit that they disagree with
your religion we don't even know anybody
anymore because advertisers are
controlling the conversation not
coercively but we're afraid that if I
say what I really think about God about
sex about how hilarious that joke was
Nabisco will no longer pay my check
that's fine you know that that's sort of
a sad thing and I'd love to see more
creativity with how we produce and
finance content did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free